foreign
yes hi I have some bad news we lost your
mom what sorry that was terrible
phrasing I meant we don't know where she
is
ah I think your sister's here and it's
finally happened oh my God it's okay
it's okay I'm here we're open oh my God
you're working
dead
she ran away that and yum your Mom
owes me 80 grand when you have it you'll
get your dog back I don't have any money
you can sell your eggs might sound like
you're using them no there has to be
another way
what is the square root of 196 14
correct how many hearts does an octopus
have very correct what saffron Saturn
Aphrodite Apollo Aries carbon dioxide
the equal sign correct oh my God what
you know this game this is how you're
gonna make the money
Drive
racing
oh
hi
come on it's gonna be fun I'm not
sleeping on the floor I'm not sleeping
on the floor either put them on the
chair
I don't want to sleep in a sitting
position oh my God
I can't play on live TV in front of
millions of people unless you get to it
and you gotta get through hair and
makeup I already went through hair and
makeup well and you missed the spot I
can't do this am I sweating yeah you
know what put your arms down you're
having a panic attack doctors prescribe
these is that cocaine
Stevia do you ever use Stevia the
sweetener yeah yeah I've got in my
pocket
win or lose we'll do it together
that is definitely broken I bet you I
could pop it back in my sound no idea
I'm going to throw
how can I ever thank you maybe like a
drink later well I'm married
I'm gay
why did that say two reasons
foreign
[Music]